Coolio passed away today I just saw that
before we walked into this room and it's
just so tragic I feel like we were
losing so many people at too young of an
age especially some of our great hip-hop
artists over the years Coolio has died
and in the wake of his death Hollywood's
reacting Julio he made some great songs
that were so fun and just a soundtrack
to you know our lives during that time
and to see that he's passed away I think
so early and tragically it's really sad
and you know I just wish the best for
his family and everybody who loved him
shortly after news broke the rapper died
at age 59 several musicians chimed in
like Ice Cube who tweeted quote this is
sad news I witnessed firsthand this
man's grind to the top of the industry
rest in peace the only thing that I can
say is that uh we we are happy that we
was able to do something
that was received so well by so many
people and
um obviously it must be something good
MC Hammer also sent his condolences
writing one of the nicest dudes I've
known good people R.I.P Coolio and Snoop
Dogg kept it simple quoting one of
Coolio's biggest hits Gangsta's Paradise
R.I.P I guess they can't I guess they
won't I guess they front that's why I
know my life is out of love food
[Music]
that song was the lead single off the
Dangerous Minds soundtrack the 1995
drama starring Michelle Pfeiffer on
Instagram the actress shined a light on
Coolio's career writing quote as some of
you may know I was lucky enough to work
with him on Dangerous Minds in 1995. he
won a Grammy for His Brilliant song on
the soundtrack which I think was the
reason our films saw so much success
[Music]
I remember him being nothing but
gracious 30 years later I still get
chills when I hear the song sending love
and light to his family I can't believe
in
in being a star and I'm only a human so
that's what I do I just
walk on the ground Coolio also appeared
on 90 sitcoms Sabrina the Teenage Witch
what's going on Coolio cool the series
star Melissa Joan Hart remembered the
rapper's kind demeanor writing I had the
amazing honor to work and play with
Coolio a few times and he was always
down for a chat a complete gentleman and
a ton of fun to hang with what a loss
rest in peace Keenan Thompson and Kel
Mitchell are paying tribute to Coolio
famously collaborated with the comedy
duo multiple times first on the kids
comedy sketch show all that don't you
remember me you came in Good Burger a
few months ago and I suppose Shake all
over your pants huh yeah don't do it
again Keenan expressed his shock on
Instagram writing wait now Coolio rest
in power and Kel he posted a full
tribute reflecting quote that first time
meeting you on all that cracking up in a
good burger sketch then you bringing me
on stage after your performance to
Freestyle then later creating the
legendary theme song for Keenan and I
[Music]
will also recalled the last time he
spoke with cool though a few months ago
quote you told me you love how I keep
things positive and to keep doing that I
will Coolio and thank you for sharing
your light and your talent with us all
and thank you for inspiring so many in
your lyrics
[Music]